that's always a good sound it seems like
we are
finally getting back to some sort of
normal after this crazy year
so restrictions on capacity social
distancing and wearing a mask
that will be lifted here in clark county
starting next tuesday
and widespread vaccines are now
available but as you know we have to
tell you it's been
not been an easy road if we go back in
time this time last year vegas looked
like a ghost town here's some video can
you believe that no cars on the strip
there
we were all waiting for strip casinos to
reopen and phase
two of governor siselek's reopening plan
to start
and what we thought would last maybe a
couple of months continued for well over
a year
so if we fast forward to now we're
finally back at memorial day weekend
which as you know
is always really busy here in town
casinos resorts restaurants and a lot
more
they're already this morning for those
expected record crowds
starting today and this weekend it is a
testament to the resilience of our city
and just how quickly it's rebounded
from rock bottom so it's nice to see
people getting back to work and those
businesses
reopening as well